does god answer prayers uh well there's
a way to say hello again i haven't seen
you in a while uh
hopeball as well i'm i'm doing all right
i'll i'll get to that in uh in a couple
of seconds here it's been a
rough grind this summer um not that you
asked sometimes i do that with customer
service representatives
i uh i say hey how are you today and
they say
uh fine and i say oh i'm doing well too
thanks for asking and sometimes i get a
surprise look on their face
and sometimes they ask for me to be
escorted by security so it's hit and
miss
you know not not all of these can be
gems um some of you not all of you been
wondering where i've been uh
i wanted to be clear you know for people
who watch the show we take a three-week
break uh every december around christmas
and
july right after the week of the fourth
of july so we actually broadcast through
the week of the fourth of july
uh and then three weeks and you see a
three-week break we actually take a
two-week break and we work on some
production stuff
now this year it's been a little bit
longer we'll be coming back
monday august 10th monday august 10th
and the schedule's going to be a little
bit different it's going to be a little
more heavy duty
not quite mug club quarantine month but
um we'll be doing good morning mug club
every day monday through thursday and
every single time
there's a debate going on which let's be
real probably won't happen but they'll
fill up with something else or a town
hall going into election
we'll be covering that for as long as it
lasts uh with a live stream
at night so um a pretty busy schedule
and uh
i i you know i did want to get to by the
way this is a shirt
officer david dorn will be this is a
this is actually in beta
can you bait a shirt does this i don't
know if
i mean i am beta wearing the shirt but
it's like beta testing we have
we have a finalized version that's more
inkjet nice and softer
so i don't feel like i'm being punished
by a mistress at
lyderworthcrowdershop.com
that's available in all proceeds all
profits from the sales of that shirt
will be going to a david dorn's family
directly so um
yeah we had to take a little bit of a
longer break and i wanted to fill you in
and then kind of get back to the idea of
god answering prayers because
i will tell you this i've experienced
the closest direct
answer um in a way that could be
quantified to prayer
uh that i can think of
at least in my adult life i could be
wrong don't hold me to that
it was a rough uh month for those of you
who may not know um
my uh wife oh let's just get out
my we had a miscarriage in the family
and then my wife had to undergo a basic
procedure
uh and she woke up paralyzed from the
waist down so this was happening the
last two weeks that i was doing the show
uh during covet so it was a nightmare
and when it happened
my mom was with her so i couldn't go and
visit her for 24 hours
um turns out she had something called uh
well she has something called
gbs and uh that's a an autoimmune
condition
of the nerves usually it's triggered by
something like a a bacteria sometimes
it's a flu shot in this case
we don't know exactly what it was it
could have been a reaction to anesthetic
um
this is actually actually a challenge to
people out there go and watch there was
a guest interview that we had to
pre-tape
because of hospital visits where i had
just heard that my wife was diagnosed
with gbs because before that there were
checks that they were checking her
pelvic plexus her back
uh and saying we hope it's not gbs and
then they called and said that it was
and that was about five minutes before i
had to go take the guest segment my face
went white
so you might so go back and watch the
last few shows uh tell me if you can
recognize which one and i'll give you
the answer on monday uh
again monday august 10th as to what it
was but uh
i tried to keep up appearances love all
about my paradise from the waist down
all of my favorite parts i'm a dick so
um anyway my wife's not offended so why
should you be
we had a lot to do with this was a back
and forth they didn't know it was gbs
one doctor said it was and one doctor
said it wasn't we couldn't get him
because the covenant with the hospital
despite there being no
real covet cases at this time the whole
thing was an absolute nightmare and of
course the only person i've ever known
uh who'd encountered gps before died
because it can paralyze your muscle my
wife is paralyzed from the waist down
and then i can paralyze your muscles up
to your diaphragm look at that david
dorn shirt
a lot of cutter shop.com and then you
actually need a ventilator
not like covered vent like you like you
know some doctors are using ventilators
some are saying that you're better off
using the cpap machine
you need a ventilator because you're
you're diaphragmatic muscles like they
cannot move
um so that was kind of a saga we were
doing the show
uh for the last two week last two weeks
amidst that
and she's to be clear she's improved now
she went from wheelchair to walker to
kane
and now she's hobbling around and uh and
we're actually training
betty to be a physical therapy dog where
my wife can actually lean on her
like a little uh like a little cane like
a little dog cane uh
and i told the trainers i don't think
that he's going to be a physical therapy
dog and she told me well it's good to
see that one of us has faith in her
abilities and i said no i have faith in
some abilities i just don't think that
standing still at a costco when there's
a golden doodle nearby is one of them
but she's making really really great
progress so this happened we're dealing
with my wife in gbs and all priorities
obviously
we're making sure that we take care of
her and i knew that we're going to have
to take a little bit of a longer break
than normal because
uh it's just hard to manage all these
duties and i had something going on with
my foot
and uh finally my wife was settling in a
little bit and she was off the
wheelchair and she was on the walker and
i said okay are you good okay
oh my foot well i thought i had a brown
recluse bite
so good old dr troy told me to go to the
emergency room i went to the emergency
room and the guy said
well you know what it's not uh or sorry
urgent care whatever it is they have
these
clinics where you can actually pay cash
go and be seen immediately or in canada
as we used to refer to that
a fantasy so i went in i was seen in
about five minutes and the guy said it's
not about recluse fight that's a good i
said great he said it's worse it's mrsa
it's staff
i said damn it and uh they had me on two
antibiotics and prednisone
long story short the pharmacist said are
there any pharmacists out there
i'm not entirely sure i know there's a
lot of schooling but anytime i ask a
pharmacist
a question just like i don't know
there's a pain aisle i said what's best
for a headache because an ibuprofen is a
temple i don't know you can look on the
label
so the pharmacist says oh these are some
heavy duty antibiotics you should use a
probiotic and i said well you know i
drink kefir and stuff and she said nah
you should take an actual probiotic i
said okay which one
and she recommended me uh
garden of eden garden of life i don't
know you probably know what i'm talking
about 80 billion cfus
lots of lots of foods and
turns out it was the pro regularity
probiotic which is not really what you
want with an antibiotic because
regularity isn't really a problem
and for me it was really just two weeks
of don't poop my pants don't poop my
pants don't poop my pants don't poop my
pants success
but it wasn't really uh enjoyable so um
before i go into kind of answered
prayers uh this is i want to say it's
been a rough
month but honestly i i cannot com
obviously my wife
has had it rougher than i have uh i
cannot complain by the way if you've
never had staph infection in your foot i
think there's b-roll right i think we
showed you a picture i don't know
um don't get on a plane
that deca it was like a migraine in my
foot it's the second worst pain i've
ever experienced
first worst pain you'll never know about
um it's embarrassing
so uh again august 10th is when we will
be back and we have a video coming out
this fall
this uh this thursday actually uh we
tried to tape some change my minds in
portland those didn't happen because
bullets uh it was a little bit too much
of a security risk
but we have some good stuff coming down
the pike
so i wanted to talk about something that
was a very clear answer to the prayer uh
speaking of of betty betty's been a very
fun very difficult dog to know betty is
to love her but um
not if you own her let me explain she's
a lot of
fun but she just is very
she just she uh she doesn't she doesn't
listen and we've taken her to dog
trainers now she's with a dog trainer
who really seems to be working well with
her and i'm pretty good with dogs but
that even went out to caesar milan's
ranch i think i told you it wasn't
really a caesar thing but a guy who
works with them and
it's just as tough when you have a dog
that doesn't have a mean bone in their
body but just
you know hey go screw yourself she
couldn't care less about what you tell
her
um and we realized that women would
board betty okay i realize this anyway i
want to tell you the story because it
comes back to an answer to prayer
um she just we would see her on
instagram she was living a best life she
just
they call her the welcoming committee at
the dog uh the dog boarding she loves
playing with dogs she's just surrounded
she just wants to if she would have a
way she'd be covered in dogs her whole
life she just loves playing with dogs so
much she's a playful pup
the problem when she comes home i notice
that she gets a little bit mopey
um and i knew that we could never be a
family that has
you know four or five or 50 dogs like
these uh
sort of dog boarding facilities and so i
felt guilty um
like we were sort of robbing betty of of
what it was that she was
most happy with now let me be really
clear about this here um
a lot of people say my dogs are like my
family and then they go oh i moved to an
apartment that doesn't take dogs oh well
you want them that's not your family
that's not your family that's
a piece of furniture that you like to
put in a sweater vest every halloween
with a pumpkin hat
don't tell me it's family i have never
rescued purchased a dog with anything
other than full intent and have to own
it for
the entirety of its life period i adapt
my life to the dog because i took on
that responsibility not saying it's as
important as a human
but that is a responsibility that i take
on through no fault of the dog
it's reliant on me but with betty i did
feel a little convicted that hey you
know
there are a lot of people who want to
funny enough but
gerald thinks he wants betty a lot of
people are asking to take betty and it's
just like what about bob
i'll be better steven no you won't betty
you're just saying you will
so she everyone else loves her because
they don't have to deal with her at
night when she gets the zoomies
but we realize that it really calms her
down to have other dogs and so i was
really afraid
in approaching this brushing this topic
with my wife
um because i know betty's kind of her
project and i got betty for her for
christmas and uh
i know it upset her to even float this
idea but i said hey hilary can we sit
down can we talk about this
i say no i notice that betty really
really likes being around other dogs
and um a part of me feels a little
guilty that we can't really provide
that for her in this house um
[Music]
and only if we think that we could find
another dog that we could bring into the
house
uh and provide the kind of life that it
wants with the family you know like
hopper used to love
his stuff being around us he would hate
he could never be boarded it would be it
would be
traumatic traumatic for him he'd have
ptsd like rambo just with treats going
across
going across the site it wouldn't work
for hoffer but betty loves it
and i said should we maybe consider
finding another dog for this home and
finding a home for betty and
my wife actually said you know what i've
actually been afraid to bring that up
with you
because i felt this way for a while um
but i just really don't want to give up
betty i love her i just i feel bad that
she's not super happy here
and we both said we said okay well
we don't want to give up betty but we
want to give her the best flip how about
this how about
we ask a friend of ours who's actually a
guy who was boarding betty we said how
about we ask if he has any dogs to
foster
and if there's a good dog out there that
we can foster
and in the house you know plays with
betty maybe that'll be enough maybe
one other dog will be enough and she'll
be happy and it'll be good for the other
dog it'll be good for betty it'll be
good for us and everyone will be happy
we won't have to
you know send betty away to her best
life
so i said okay i love that plan well
four days later to the day
someone messages me i think through
instagram a fan who watches the show
didn't didn't know where i lived just
said hey i know that you lost hopper in
december
um and you have doug argentinos and
they're pretty you know pretty powerful
breed pretty
pretty particular um wanted to know if
you wanted another male
because our male doggo just doesn't get
along with an older male that we've had
who's kind of getting up there in age
and
um they're kind of going at it and we're
about to have a baby and it's
just not the best situation for him we
love him uh we really would like him to
go to a good house it's obvious you love
your dogs
long letter saw a picture about stopped
my heart
because the picture looked like hopper
but bigger and uh run a search
this lady was eight minutes away from
where i was at that time i could have
been anywhere in the country eight
minutes away
so let me introduce betty to uh uh to
lewis who is now known as joe lewis with
her permission named after the
best heavyweight boxer of all time in
honor of him um i always just changed
the name a little bit so you know kind
of ditching their previous name
ditching the slave name converting the
nation of islam you know that thing and
uh
we saw him from afar it is a big dog
bigger than 110 pounds
and
there's so much i can get back and forth
long story short
betty and joe lewis are obsessed with
each other
absolutely obsessed with each other you
have some footage here they eat together
they sleep together it's like
it's like lady in the [ __ ] where they
share toys together
uh they seem like they're killing each
other all the time because that's the
way dog goes play but they absolutely
adore
each other they can't get enough of one
another and it makes
our lives easier because it runs their
energy down
and here you go right now is there's
little joe lewis crowder right joe lewis
well like i said he's an easy dog you
can't really see him because he's curled
up like a little powdered donut
but um it came in
within the week after hillary and i we
both had it on our heart for a very long
time
we were going through a rough time
health-wise uh
and and come to a decision together
after prayer
and it just dropped into our lap in a
scenario that couldn't have been better
uh and couldn't have ended up better
because it's
really just enriched our family and
listen hopefully i appreciate the
prayers out there i know that those have
been following me on instagram um
hopefully a family that'll be complete
with little crowders soon we've been
working on it it's something that i've
kept close to the chest for a while but
i appreciate the kind words
and uh we will be back again august
oh fine oh oh oh oh oh oh question
my wife because she you know she's gimpy
she's gimpy
it's a little gross but you know
something i have to learn to deal with
uh i need to buy a new car
with adaptive cruise control and stuff
because for the next year i don't know
what flexion this is is that dorsal
flexion or is that a dolphin
this part with her foot the pressing is
gonna be the last thing to come back
so either a choice is housebound or
a car and i really i would rather not
have to get something like a tesla but i
understand that uh
some of the domestic cars a lot of them
have this sort of
self-driving features that would make my
wife's life a lot easier if there's
someone
i don't know a whole lot about cars get
me from point a to point b ideally it
goes
you know broom broom fast uh if anyone
knows uh
of the best cars that would be suitable
for a a very pretty but
gimpy wife i would appreciate it uh
august 10th
monday we are going to be back that's
every day good morning mug club and the
special live streams but uh i also of
course want to leave you
with this announcement for the david
dorn church
retired st louis police captain david
dorn doran was shot and killed by a
looter earlier this week in north st
louis this was a great cop great cops do
exist
and this is one of black lives have to
matter to us first
so until then we're gonna keep on having
these instances
of stupid
killings and stuff like that my uncle
didn't deserve to die like that
[Music]
you